hey there i'm conan o'brien welcome to
sirius jibber jabber i'm here
with the emmy
and tony award-winning actor
and comedian martin short oh yeah oh
cricket stop for you yeah very nice yay
he of course starred in the
groundbreaking sketch comedy series sctv
he's also a cast member on saturday live
and has appeared in numerous films
including the father of the bride uh
movies clifford three amigos he's done
so much you can't put it all
on don't you want to talk about the tony
oh plural
multiple tonys three tonys really two
daytime tonys but one full night time do
they look any different you're littler
and they're made of candy aren't they
you're edible um i'm going to start by
saying something i
haven't said to anybody
uh
are you a jew uh i'm allowed to ask you
that
uh
no here's here's my question
i've been in this business now since
1985.
can i make a call during this part go
ahead this will be quick and you're
going to like it because i can't hear
about the whole there's one name i
reliably hear
funniest guy ever
martin short really yes
consistently
you why how have you perpetuated this
fraud this long you know that though you
know that and i know there's really no
response for you but it's why i wanted
to talk to you in this environment
because that's very kind you know it's
pretty i think it's a subjective thing i
think that you would find people
when this is on if you go down to the
comments
they'll say what i can say i can see
them now i can see them now
there's a lot i don't know i mean but it
is don't you find the most fascinating
thing about comedy is that it's a
subjective thing some people love
slapstick some people hate it some
people admire the stooges some people
don't i'll say this
i think if you're looking if you get all
the concentric circles and you have them
uh intersect in one area
i think there are very few people that
you can get just about everybody to
agree on
you are one of them
uh i'm gonna put steve martin in that
category as well and then
you start having arguments but there's
not an argument when you say
jesus christ martin short is the
funniest guy ever
every time i've seen you do anything you
score
reliably i'd like to know the secret how
do you do it how can i do it
how can i steal your life's essence
that's what i want well i mean i don't
know what to say i do believe though um
like for talk shows for example
my instinct is always to really over
prepare
you send in
you know 30 pages initially have them
cut down to eight pages that will never
be you no one will get to all that
material and if in fact if you go out
and just start doing your material
then the appearance will be a failure
because
it won't be a conversation it will just
be a rather tattered but
that over preparation gives you this
confidence not just that you
like you're going out with something but
also for me it's also tied to this idea
that if i bomb
i'll still be able to go and have a
glass of wine and celebrate because i
did everything i could do i can't help
it if i'm limited
[Laughter]
you just want that wine is all you want
and i'll get you your wine
one agreement uh
to me that is one of the keys
you do it and steve martin does it but
you
what i've noticed
is and it's not just in comedy but
particularly holds in comedy is that the
people that
that really astonish me
are the people that work really hard
even though they probably don't have to
to me that's what separates you i've
seen the notes when when whenever
frank smiley produces your segment we've
done many shows together yes
30 pages of notes of you testing out
different stories uh the level of work
that goes in there's a hair of neediness
to it
yes she's named my book
awful awful title awful title um how
about sonny von bulow unplugged we have
that option okay this is i i refer does
it look infected how about that title
we'll go with that the new testament i'm
thinking that's good that's been taken
uh
let's talk about where it comes from
which is we go back
and i think anybody who's in this
business of comedy we'll call it that
for tonight
even if this is tonight i have no idea
what time it is we shoot this in a salt
mine
it's four in the morning in a safe house
it's a safe house uh it's gotta start
when you're a kid it has to that's where
you learn that you're funny so let's
start was your dad funny he was a funny
guy my dad was very funny my dad was
very sarcastic
very funny and when i started doing
jiminy glick i realized that i was also
channeling
his thing like he would my father was
irish born in ireland so what he would
do is that he never and he was very
successful he's the vice president of
the steel company of canada so he was an
executive he had a bar for example in
his office that he'd never touch but the
second he'd come home
you know gin and ginger no ice and he'd
sit there and read the paper he never
ate with us because he'd always had his
big meal at lunch so he'd see us all the
400 kids
sitting there and
don't you don't shovel it in like an
animal don't you don't need to or he can
i get up on this thing you could do
whatever you want sometimes he'd be
running the pit we'd look over and he'd
just get up with this
right michael keep eating i'll make sure
that dogs don't get out y'all probably
and it was just like ah dad would you
just leave
the room let us
you know one time uh they don't have a
cloth or a clean accident well i'll just
do it imagine
it's like i was cleaning the counter
and i bunched it up like this
and then he
he said
he could he could watch that for about
eight seconds and he'd grab it look only
a [ __ ]
now you got a big space so it was always
very not critical but ultimately right
you know and and very funny and everyone
um was funny in my family i was the
youngest so it was almost like trickle
down funny right it was and and and we
have tapes that you know we used to
always make tapes did you make tapes in
your yeah i made well i made audio i
didn't have any audio the same audio
yeah but it was it was
real and and we'd make comedy tapes and
the sleazy awards and you know we'd do
all this stuff but my mom would be there
laughing in one of the characters too so
she was
not
funny funny but laughing and
appreciating and if she'd bomb we'd make
fun of her bombing and so there i think
comedy was
very
dominant in my house and i think though
that for me as a youngest
not only did i steal from everybody but
because i was you know never really
touched the ground until i was 11 or
something that i was given all this
confidence
oh marty marty and then i was stealing
everyone's bits i think how many
brothers and sisters i was youngest of
five
i was middle of six and i believe
most of my timing
most of my instincts got worked out
around the kitchen table absolutely
because i think there's a rough and
tumble
you it's just abrasion you just you
figure out what works what doesn't work
and it starts when you're very irish too
i think that there's a there's a
level of sarcasm and darkness and anger
i remember my my father was born and
raised in crossing glen county arma
above shorts bar well the shorts bar
which is still there by the way
and um his father was republican
and as they call it james short
and
it up until two years ago he died was
run by my uncle patty the youngest of
the 11 kids and i remember one night
paddy's two sons and i stayed up to
about five in the morning talking about
family i was visiting and staying over
and we
you know we were drinking beer and then
you go to whiskey
but when with if if you're the owner if
the if you're the kids of the pub owner
you don't you have to pay you have to
keep putting money in the tool you can't
just drink the whiskey so anyway i came
down around nine in the morning and
patty uncle patty was cleaning out the
glasses and he just looked so how did
the character assassination go last
night
and it was course spot on
and i thought that's great just edgy
funny
well you know there's a
am i wrong if it felt to me when i was a
kid anyway that we weren't allowed to be
overtly impolite but if we could be
funny about it
you can get away with murder you could
could be edgy yeah so you can express
anger and displeasure i mean i would see
these other families i've had friends
that from from other cultures and other
ethnicities and they're yelling at each
other openly in front of it we never did
that in my house no but it was all could
you swear at your father no no i
couldn't even oh my god
no i can't now now that he you know he i
routinely break him over the goals now
he's uh well he doesn't like me to
mention his age let's just say he's
really up there yeah uh he's 84. well
you're
gonna say you're i am 50
50. yeah
i think that's fun when you say that
everyone can google stuff you know
anyway what's your next question
58
64. thank you
[Laughter]
let's talk about canada all right uh i
and we've talked about this many times
sctv was a revelation to me when i was
very interested in comedy
and a lot of people were talking about
saturday night live and i thought sc tv
was for me specifically
and then i found out that there were a
lot of people like me
who thought that sctv was just for them
the level of detail
and the fact that there wasn't a live
audience i thought made a big difference
which is interesting to me because
you so much thrive on a live audience
and you were a huge success on saturday
live but there was something about well
i did i i did sc tv in the next year
right did senate live and it was
hugely
hugely different
pieces that you could write
um
i remember i wrote this piece in saturn
live
i swear it would have killed an fctv
because we would have edited it we would
have done it it was a television
commercial i mean a promo for a
fictitious tv show the idea that lucy
was coming back one more time right and
the show uh was called look who's
married harry and she's playing best
truman
and we're in the oval office and i had
the red wig and i had the buttons and on
the
vest
and i'm saying eleanor roosevelt played
by mary help me girl we got a wallpaper
before harry and it was
just talk about crickets i mean it
bombed on a level at dress it was just
nothing and i thought well of course
because it doesn't look like a
television promo
and what we could do in sctv is we could
take that we put the sound and we'd
shoot it the right way
uh it was surgical in a way it was you
could be surgically precise about comedy
and sctv and there's some standout live
is a cultural yeah well they took the
time it was very i remember there was an
uh john candy and i was near the end of
a season
uh on nbc and
you know they come into a certain point
and say look guys we do not have we have
three hours to shoot something so if
anyone can write something that would
take three hours to shoot we could shoot
it it's gonna take eight hours guys we
can't do it
absolutely so uh my brother michael and
i wrote this piece whatever happened to
baby ed and i was edgar mean john candy
was the tormenting older brother but he
had the hair too and i'm in the
wheelchair and i'm practicing my
wheelchair
and it was a really funny script and we
shot it
and you just knew it wasn't working and
we go over to the prom because they're
shooting with four cameras because they
only have right two hours to shoot at me
i go over to the
i say why isn't this working
and candy says i don't know why isn't it
working
and then john said because it doesn't
actually look like a movie so now the
director john blanchard got into a huge
fight with the producer james paul rock
saying we need eight hours to shoot this
over up shoot it exactly remember i
remember the show yeah
people
there was a big fight and john and i
went over and took us a cigarette and
because we all the cast always won those
things because we were the show we wrote
the show controlled the show
it wasn't like saturn live where you
know clearly lorne michaels is the head
of that show this
andrew alexander was fantastic running
it but he knew to stay out of the way of
everybody
i mentioned canada you just mentioned
lauren michaels it's a question that
it's a boring question by this point
what is it about canadians but i need to
go there because i have worked with
so many comedians and there's a very
specific kind of comedy that seems to
come out of canada that i can never put
my can never put my finger on it but
what is it what's in the water in canada
i don't know
i used to i was asked that all the you
know a long time and i used to think oh
that's you know comedy is international
there's no such thing and then i kept
seeing these people and then you know
phil hartman and mike meyer and they
just kept coming and jim carrey and i
thought let's do something and i do
think it is that canada got the pythons
before you got the pie i don't mean got
it but like saw them right so we would
see american television canadian
television
and british television i also think it's
a smaller we're kind of like the middle
sibling you know you got the the like
the uh
the sexy young
kind of
you know united states you've got the
older emma thompson british and there's
this kind of middle
sibling who's much
prettier and more fabulous than she
might at times think but it gives her
that thing of snapping at people and
making fun and then hiding and and
also i think behavior
odd behavior is more kind of um
revered there i used to see second city
there was for a long time
just second city chicago and then in 73
it moved to toronto and if you saw the
two
shows back to back you'd see the chicago
show and it'd be very well written very
smart political edgy then you go up to
toronto i mean catherine o'hare and
robin duke playing two drunk
female truckers and it was just
character work so bizarre
and i personally was laughing more at
the toronto stuff so
um i don't know if that's an answer to
the question but i i because i know but
there is something about that that
middle child syndrome and it's also am i
right it seems like it's a very
literate country there's a and i don't
just mean reading but i mean there's a
it seems like a lot of the comedians
have this vast knowledge of movies
film they're
well educated in a way about they're
certainly well educated in satire yeah i
mean i think that the era where
character work became more important
than the punch line right was a great
great boom for canadian comedy because
they they could create these characters
that didn't
have
any punch lines well that's what yeah so
steve martin i just did a show with
steve the other night and he's a good
friend obviously but
on
part of our show is we will talk about
these things and and steve was talking
about this thing where he just decided
to take out all punch lines
and just see what happened right what
happened is that he bombed for a couple
years but then he would be forced to
create
it seemed like that he felt was the new
world of comedy and when you think of
you know
bill murray singing feelings there's no
jokes there it's just
total attitude
total
approach to
comedy in a way that doesn't force you
to be involved and yet takes you
completely
uh into its soul because it's saying you
know that guy
join me in this little journey and don't
just hear my jokes there's an aggressive
uh
in a lot of your work there's there's
almost uh i defy you to figure out
how i came up with this guy uh the
quality to it and and i mean this is a
as a compliment but i can
when bill murray made fun of the lounge
singer i knew where it was coming from
and so many people i would know where it
was coming from and then there's an ed
grimly
and it was
it did feel like it was coming from
another dimension and i loved it but
couldn't for the life of me figure out
how you came up with ed grimley
it doesn't he it's not someone you
didn't see an ed grimly no one's ever
seen an ed grimley no i didn't see any
grimly but i did know a guy in school
and he always talked like that
he wanted to be a photographer
he'd say hey stan
would you do this we took a lot of
slides
can i see them well i didn't develop
them because like i took them so i knew
what they were so i didn't feel they
needed to be developed
pretty savvy stan says i
and then it just kind of stays with you
and and um so then that was like when
i'm 16 now i'm uh
you know whatever 26 and i'm doing
second city uh yeah second city and
there was a character that it was a
scene called sexist and the scene was um
uh
peter aykroyd brother of danny catherine
o'hara and i katherine is an amazingly
qualified person for the same job i work
at an esso station in the corner of
jackson and wilson street i must say
and that was the scene and the and we
ended the you know i end up getting the
job and that's the same and she does a
tirade and storms off and one i used to
put a little grease in my hair just to
do it and peter ackroyd said to me one
night that hair is standing strong
taller every night so to make him laugh
i put it right up
and the audience laughed and i thought
well isn't this why i'm here so i just
kept that and then i realized it was
kind of like an abstract painting but
there was a simplicity to him
and when i moved to saturn live i
couldn't do those quieter scenes anymore
that i would do and but i so i had to
explore ed's world of in his apartment
and his obsession with
wheel of fortune and
um
uh you know talking
that the phone rang yeah i love the
phone there's always such a sense of
mystery which so there was truth to it
well his uh you also did nathan
nathan thurm
and
opposite end of the spectrum like
there's a character
who
[Music]
it's all about
getting in
really close and the quietness of it in
a way and uh
it's very small i mean to me that was
impressive i noticed that at the time as
a comedy fan that you've gone
well i always found that richard nixon
when he went on and and defended
you know that he didn't know why those
18 minutes were missing from that tape i
found that hysterical
because first of all there was all this
sweat here
so it's like he's lying
we know he's lying and he knows we know
he's lying and yet he's i would never
and i just found that hysterical so
nathan therm
that's why i put sled up here and then
it was a 60 minutes uh it was a 60
minute parody there was a there was a
makeup artist
at saran live i won't mention her name
she was the most defensive
uh
person that you'd ever met in your life
she always chained smoke so joe to
cigarettes
and i'd say gee mary and i seem a little
pale i know that you don't think i know
that i know that i'm in a makeup artist
i even know that
okay so so so now we got to you know
it's a month later and harry shearer and
christopher guest and billy chris and i
are writing a satire of 60 minutes
and uh they i'm going to play the lawyer
that's always being cross-examined by
mike wallace played by harry shearer and
i
will um
you know be defensive and i didn't know
who to play it and billy crystal said
why don't you do marion siebert i just
said the name
and i he said
he said why don't you do her i said well
i can't do
her she's going to find out that i'm
doing it ah she'll never find out they
never find out
so um then we're doing it
and uh
and then but i forgot she'd be there of
course when we shot it so i'm mike
wallace's
i'm saying i know that you don't think i
know that i'm a lawyer i would know that
and they go cut he's sweating she goes i
know that you don't think i know that
[Laughter]
she didn't figure it out she didn't
figure that
she never figured out except she never
figured and then on saturday live as you
know
better than anyone when something a
character works they repeat it and every
time i did it i was terrified
that i get caught and i never got caught
and then the last show
there was a big party and her assistant
got drunk
marion how stupid are you
you're nathan therm don't you know that
so she confronted me i thought you were
my friend and i said i am your friend
but you know that
impersonation is the highest form of
compliment and she said i know that you
don't think i know that
she uh well you immortalized her yeah i
guess yeah i guess we'll bleep her name
i guess thank you uh
jiminy glick
uh
yeah but again
there are all these aspects of jimmy
like his cartoonish
body
it's you encased in this fat suit but
that seems to be so important to him
i've i i love jiminy glick
i loved him when you did him in your
broadway show and
you had you you let me come up and
that's true together uh improv and i
know you can do that and you also did
primetime glick yes and i but there was
something about
that absurd body it almost feels like
that gives you license as jiminy glick
there's something about being in that
suit i don't that seems to help you
it seems to give you a license to be
well
sort of the suit was great because i
could fall oh yeah because i had the
padding
um it definitely allowed me to say
things that i would never ever ever say
to people you know
um
you know i
um
sometimes you just hush someone shh just
because i ask you a question doesn't
mean i need an answer
and
but no one got upset when one person got
upset but you know most people who got
upset i can't say it
gotcha tell you at dinner that would be
fun yeah and then i'll tweet it out and
then everybody will know
no i should be able to tell the story
but i i you know i'm too kind i'm too
sweet this is interesting you are a uh
i think we may have some similarity here
i you're a very nice person i think of
myself as a nice person comedy is my way
to not be so nice
walk this line of i mean i have running
a thousand running bits with my staff
right playing over the top
right ogre character yeah yeah quiet you
shut up i grab comedy writers i i've
pushed people up against the wall i'm
constantly
uh
insulting them in a variety of ways it's
not really me but it's a way
well no no i think you're satirizing
someone who's like that don't you think
i hope so or i'm an [ __ ] i know well
little bits of everything yeah thank you
my point is what is your point your
point is that my point is that you are a
seem like you always seems to me like a
very nice guy but but you can take it
right to the edge you can
you have a razor's edge uh
uh i don't want to say cruelty but
you're able
you're able to take it right up to the
line and and get away with it and
audiences love it i mean routinely every
time you come on my show you open with a
barrage of my makeup the bad work i've
had done
and you're playing i said you i said to
you that i appreciated the work that
cosmetic surgery you had my only
suggestion was 20 more
part of you means it uh not true an
awful part no no no you can never go for
the real no no no no no no no no but you
can't go to the real stuff right you
can't go to uh you know if someone has a
big stomach can't say nice stomach
that's mean right
uh but
you could say this is pi i'm sure you'd
like that you know you can do that
you fat [ __ ]
no i mean i think that um
i know i think
like when you satirize someone when you
when you impersonate someone yes
uh i did pieces uh two pieces in essay
tv where i play jerry lewis
and it was very important to me
to show within those pieces that jerry
lewis was really
funny
i could show other sides that might make
it ultimately be like a hirschfeld
sketch but if you
denied why that person was famous and
revered and just went to the mean stuff
then there's no
there's no satire right it's it's not
layered
and jerry
later quasi-approved of your
well yeah i i i i was asked because i
think you you you uh you did a hardly
working i mean you really
you did the jerry lewis
uh scenes from an idiot's marriage yeah
jerry lewis working with bergman
the lozenge the laws in here
always thought that jerry lewis
even if he didn't have a lozenge
either seemed like he had a lozenge in
his mouth or should
so we'd talk about
why the studios were run by fools today
oh loss of joe put it there but he can
produce another one instantly from
within this i don't know where they're
coming from
i mean i can only he's a dispenser of
laws and just spends her lozenge uh
what's the era
of show business that if you if you were
a magical man you could go is there an
era of show business that you would
prefer or that you identify with
um i i probably
um
would say
i don't know i mean is it is it i used
to
love 1962 i was 12. i used to think what
a great thing there's frank
there's sammy there's you know all these
funny people
on tv jackie gleason jonathan winters
but that's i don't think it's so much
because that's the era
i want to live in i think that when
you're 12
that's when you're open to it all that's
when the people that are
that's when you're most influenced
that that's the huge
time 12 to 15 or so then there's a
certain point where you say i'm just
recycling everything that i learned
between 12 and 15. you know
there's a i mean
you
you sing you dance i watched you i was
there when you did the afi tribute to
mel brooks into this opening number
and
you toss these things off
there's an incredible amount of skill
you you know this
this form of show business that a lot of
people in my generation
they don't have the command
and
well i think that in in general i mean
let's face it that there aren't you know
there aren't there's saturn live as far
as sketch shows there's not many
sketches when i was 14 15 you turned on
television and there were variety shows
there were sitcoms that there are today
through westerns and there were all the
shows that are on today but there were a
lot of sketch shows so therefore a lot
of people worked as writers in sketch
shows and they learned that craft but i
think that in
my generation there was maybe just a
little wider range of what was going on
so you could
watch it all and take a little bit of
that a little bit of that i also think
you had to know because when i was a kid
and you'd watch the variety shows
everybody it was just done if you
watched a
bob hope
you know variety show
everybody had to sing a number at some
point yeah and you had to do some soft
shoe
and there was this thing that got
carried over i mean you think about tv
when it first began in the late 40s and
early 50s it's just
they're just taping vaudeville and
putting and showing it to people and
then that got carried on for a while to
the point where the brady bunch has a
variety show
and they all have to sing and dance
because that's what you have to do
i think that's obviously
not so much the case now i don't think
you know that there's there's as you
said there's a lot of attitude comedy
there's a lot of uh
um comedy that's almost anti-performance
but there's a lot and there's a lot of
comedy that kind of
that guy
isn't that guy stupid let's show a clip
that guy got hit in the balls let's show
a clip
that hurt we'll be back
it's not necessarily um
uh
my favorite but
mainly because i you know there's so
much so there's so much if there was
like one person doing that you'd say
that's cool
you know louis c.k you look at louis c.k
and you think what's so great about
louis ck is that he's doing what other
people do but he's doing something
different he's there's some kind of
weird
honesty
that truth that we all
he's saying things that we shouldn't
even be thinking and he's just saying it
and laughing and saying come on
you know and louie's an example of
someone who's been
working on that
forever he's always been that guy he
almost needed the medium to catch up to
him right he needed well you know you
know you look at something like john
belushi in that first cast of saturn
live you know steve martin always says
that he was an aspen
uh living there in aspen strange enough
in 1975 he had a house there
and
he watched that live the first episode
he went
they did it
they figured it out they figured out
how to take
comedy
variety and show business in general to
just this new
level in a way something that he was
trying to do too
it was just simultaneously
and but as brilliant as john belushi was
and all those guys and girls on that
cast and gilda if they hadn't had that
vehicle
who would know that they could do that
so you do need it's like why when
everyone says about being in comedy or
showbiz in general that it's it's you
know you have to have talent yes
you have to have
tremendous endurance yes and you have to
have luck you have to actually have a
vehicle
that allows you to showcase these
so-called gifts
there's uh there's an era of show
business
and clearly it's changed but
my example is the beatles on sullivan
february of 64 they go on and
you know 73 80 million people watch
there's no crime while the beatles are
performing it's a huge event
and i always say today
by the time the beatles got to sullivan
we'd all be sick of them because we'd
have watched
yeah would have doubt would have would
have seen all of their work in the
cavern club because we'd all be on video
be on that would be on youtube
that have been jammed down our throats a
million different times before they even
got over here right and they would have
been here 600 times before they ever
went on sullivan because they would have
done they would have been in the
nickelodeon kids choice awards and we
would have slimed them you know so
you make it all so pathetically sad yeah
that's the point of this sure that's it
but that's the show there was i always
feel like um
you
uh
uh
there's a there's an air of show
business that i think you're still very
strongly connected to where it's a club
which is how it used to be it used to be
a smaller club now it feels you know in
the old days you could go on carson and
doing a carson appearance
and the next day walked down the street
and everybody had seen it everybody
and today i don't think there's any one
show where anybody can go well there's
also by everyone yeah there's also you
know 900 stations and 900
ways to see things
when
i was
13
if i wanted to change the station and by
the way there were only nine
i have to get up
and walk across the room
and if you're as drunk as i was at 13
it's hard to walk without hitting your
knee yeah so you end up watching that
odd black and white
thin man thing with william powell that
you never ever ever would have watched
had you gone
and had 900 stages so
therefore obviously if they're in johnny
carson there was one talk show that was
one guy and and the other thing is there
seemed to be a unanimity about what the
topics were everybody knew
they all know who dean martin was
and that
his act is he's been drinking you know
they all knew
yeah and and everybody knew the back
story yeah and i think one of the things
today is i've seen this a million times
someone will have
a very successful show um
a show that
is a hit in its niche and they come on
the show and they say i'm going to come
out there and i'm going to start by
dropping a line from my show and they
look out to the crowd
there's no unanimous yes
yeah some people know what he's talking
about
other people don't it doesn't mean the
show isn't a hit in its world
it's just very hard for everybody to no
one's on the same page i think sometimes
comedically and i think it really you
you come from that area era where where
you grew up and i think you embody in a
lot of your comedy that era where
everybody knows the story do you know
what i mean everybody again though i
think it's just that there's
if there's a thousand things to watch
your focus is constantly i have
from having
you know that remote control and 900
stations much
less
uh tolerance for watching anything i
don't give anything a chance it seems
i'm just kind of watching and what i
mean it's a little better if you can dvr
and create your own network you know
then you you created it therefore you
commit to it a little more well
also on sdtv sign out live
you're parodying things where everybody
knows what you're parodying whereas
today
there's a pressure
too you've got to do there's a twerking
video miley cyrus twerking well like how
would you parody miley cyrus
at the award show you
you have to do it well here's the
problem you have to have the tongue that
goes right out and run drags on the
ground and is and is pinned up to the
side of your face exactly uh i would
have to have a lot of surgery to my ass
um
further surgery in my ass to have it
done but the problem is you're parroting
something that it's it's
that is the biggest miley cyrus twerking
was the biggest splash culturally in the
last
uh you know a couple of weeks good
culture to live in
thumbs up all around but you must admit
that was like a train wreck
of such insane proportions
uh i thought she was fantastic i thought
she nailed it allow me to finish my
thought
um
i'm only talking about her hairdo i
would like to have seen it down
i don't know why the devil horns i
thought the tongue was brilliant yeah
and twerking gee i mean i love twerking
yeah
the pope is introduced to working in the
catholic church now which i think is
pretty surprising it's a new era you
know that the pope francis
will not wear any fur on his capes you
know that all fur is gone is that true
yeah he decided that himself yeah except
if he has lady gaga tickets but
that is all he'll do
thank you
thank you so much uh how do you like the
no audience format i'm used to the
response absolutely
[Laughter]
let's talk about
talk show guests who
[Music]
you've earned you're you're in the
pantheon of people that always you
always deliver you're always funny
everybody
when you're on the show any show it's
day off for the host who do you feel
that way about when you see them on a
show
as a guest oh i think uh
steve
martin tom hanks hanks is another guy
tom hanks i just saw i just saw bill
murray this kind of like breathtaking
performance on dave letterman's show
where he came out as liberace
um
i think people that that
commit to it um but there's a lot of
people people
it really goes down billy crystal is
always prepared he's always funny i
think it's tied to this idea that
um
if if it's important you know one thing
about steve is that he'll phone me up
and he'll say
tell me if you think this joke is funny
so he'll go over four jokes
oh what's this for uh i have to do blank
in three months
and you're saying so you're working this
hard
on your seventh thousandth talk show
and you're steve martin and this is like
three years ago and you think
it's really that important to you that
you do well that's why i guess you're
steve martin we had uh on the old late
night show
you'd have these bands that had the hit
of the moment and they would show up
they'd make a lot of demands they wanted
to keep the nbc limo for the night
they wanted a lot of booze they wanted
this they wanted that and then
i remembered the
springsteen was on a few times every
single time he showed up early
worked it out
worked it out
was in there worked hard at rehearsal
figured it out
then was out in the hallway and then he
was in his dressing room and he was
ready to go and then afterwards hung out
chatted chatted with people was
authentically
nice and kind yeah and you thought yeah
it's it's not an accident but i think
that sometimes people
are so fearful and they're they're
wearing a mask of confidence so that
part of their fear is oh i don't need to
rehearse i'm too good
i'm too good to have to rehearse you
know and the reality is
that when you kind of have confidence in
yourself that's when you know oh i have
to rehearse because as i say everything
gets better when it's refined and you
realize oh i don't need
oh i just need that one line i can take
those three out well you have to have
studied it a little bit to know that
well i usually think it's a defense
mechanism too yeah when there's a
comedian or a musician who doesn't want
to rehearse and they say let's just wing
it or is an actor who just says let's
just wing it it's going to be great
let's just wing it i know they're scared
i know they're terrified they're
absolutely terrified are you on a coin
in canada i am the three dollar coin the
marty
there's the looney
[Laughter]
the toonie
and the marty is there let's talk about
this are you really on a coin i am on a
coin
is it your image is it your face no
i was asked by the canadian government
the mint to um design a coin a three
dollar coin that would be sold and uh so
i you know worked with this artist we
came up with this little scene kind of
like a
you know i had this cottage
uh
it's an estate but i call it a cottage
on the lakes
where is this specifically three hours
north of toronto okay i've never been or
been invited
what uh is it hard to get into
um you have to have um
really made me
belly laugh i see
i see so i mean i've seen a lot of your
stuff and it's great
but
this
belly laugh thing is what gotcha not
cottage-worthy is what you're saying so
you have this kind i've invited you many
times which is true
is it is it really it's it's
okay i've meant to invite
many many times i've thought bubbled it
uh fair enough uh that's
astounding you're you're you're a coin
i'm a three you're a three dollar coin
i'm a three dollar is there much use for
a three dollar coin in canada there's
not and you actually
there was no
it was a bad idea
no it's no it's sold it's it's actually
cost fifty dollars to buy
fifty dollars to buy a three dollar coin
yes sir
how's that economy going in canada we're
uh we're struggling
but keep in mind
i'm sure i've talked to your show but
for a while there we now have eight
teams in the cfl
but for a while there we had nine teams
not a lot of teams
two were called rough riders
the saskatchewan rough riders
and the ottawa rough riders and at times
as a kid growing up i could pass the tv
screen and i'd hear rough riders 28
rough riders 7.
and i have no idea i go
gee i'm real happy for the rough riders
and yet i'm kind of sad for the rough
ride
it by the way did not seem remotely
strange until someone tom hanks once
said to me why is it that
there are two teams rough riders years
ago because he was amazed that i used to
live on avenue road
that also
made him is there a road avenue there's
no but there's a road lane nice
now cad isn't very look canada's an
amazing country it's it's
healthcare
since 1962
the queen is the queen of canada queen
of england i mean it's 34 million people
the crime is less
streets are clean
it's a great country it's a great
country let's go
i should be there i could i could go
there with you let's go
uh we can't hit the cottage though and
kind of close that up
you don't mind that's not what i hear
yeah i have satellite images
right now
the greatest comedy
people of the century uh you met frank
sinatra i did that's got to be one of
the great highlights
it was i was always afraid i think it's
always daunting to meet a hero frank
sinatra was a hero i'm not talking about
i'm talking about the sun frank jr
no but
i i i was at this party was uh and frank
was 77 years old he's standing by at the
bar by himself with a drink
and uh i went up he was miming yeah no
there was nothing against it i couldn't
believe the agility
and uh
and uh dinah shore
uh was a famous singer i said do you
want to meet frank because she was a fan
of sctv she was hip chick
and
i said yeah and i went up
and i said mr sinatra
uh my name is martin short
it's like 1992. i said you have no idea
you have no
concept
of how
big a fan i am of yours and you just
looked at me and said
i think i do
and he said what are you drinking
i said whatever whatever you're drinking
frank and you turn the margin jack
daniels
so the bartender said straight up
we're on the rocks and i was too nervous
i thought he said straight up or relaxed
i said i'll have it relaxed and frank's
he said straight up or on the rock so
i'd already known frank 15 seconds
i pissed him off and then i thought he
assumed he'd go for the gun
he'd shoot me and i couldn't hear the
albums anymore so i left i got there
you pissed him off i pissed him within
seconds within 15 seconds i think that
it's better
yeah he's better that way what if you
become good friends the story would be
no good if we cross-country yeah
frank pass me that die pepsi shut the
[ __ ] up
frank you don't shoot the driver
that's just crazy
uh
is uh
anyone else in your family in show
business or my brother michael is a two
emmy two-time emmy winner he wrote fctv
and has been a very successful writer
for
30 years
my brother brian
is uh was is retired now he's vice
president of dover industries mr norris
anesthesiologist so you know
accomplished and you were pre-med for a
while weren't you two years how could
that have happened you seem like someone
that was born to be in show business how
could you have
what made you think for five seconds
that you would you you would go into
medicine i was a fan of quincy
i just i just
loved the way klugman could handle stuff
he was a coroner so
um no i you know i'll tell you what it
was i grew up in hamilton ontario canada
and
in the 60s you know you couldn't get
charmin
in the in canada the first thing i did
when in the united states is can i
squeeze that i mean i was fascinated
there were product bosco you couldn't
get things that i would see in american
television so america seemed like
it's like venus or something it just
didn't seem realistic i think if i'd
grown up in new york
maybe i would have had a different
uh attitude so i was literally a 14 year
old kid who was up in my attic with an
applause record a got a real real tape
cord that i had made from sinatra at the
sands and i'd recorded applause and i'd
blue
loop it loop it
so and i pretended to have my own
imaginary
television show i was on nbc
uh at 8 30 every
other tuesday
which left room for my imaginary film
career and i had an applause record
i had a gooseneck lamp because even then
i needed you know softening on the eyes
yeah we stopped and uh thanks and and i
would type things up for tv guide and
i'd you know um
do tony bennett and i'd read from
playboy and read the interview of
eldridge cleaver
your people are struggling what can i do
to help you know i'd read his part and
i'd read the other part and then so i'm
going to go dinner and then we'd take
later
and i used to do this
and yet at no time
did anyone say hey do you want to go
into show business because it just
wasn't a realistic journey the feeling
i had growing up my dad
is a a doctor and a
research scientist and a brilliant guy
and my mom was a lawyer
but
i was constantly performing for my
friends constantly and i was obsessed
with it but i never for a second thought
that it was a career i didn't see any i
remember seeing robert urich once
uh shooting uh something on the streets
of boston
and i saw robert urich
that was my exposure to show business
that was all i had was robert urich i
mean
it's not often enough no
but i i
it feels a little bit like today uh it's
a more accessible dream for anybody i
think the internet i think the
absolutely and and reality television
makes you know snooki's on the cover of
people so you go
well it must be
therefore it must be accessible to
anyone yeah um
but and i also i did i knew
right away i guess from watching
television
that the chances of being successful
were remote and i did not want to be not
successful i did in anything i did i
wanted i didn't want to be broke i
didn't so when i started
uh
in
in acting
i had done four years of university
and i thought
i will give myself one year
and if i don't make a living in one year
then i will go back to school do a
master's or something and accept it so
because i always knew that i if you
the key to it all
was to look in the mirror at 50 and say
well maybe you should have tried being
an actor and you go oh that's right you
did try being an actor no one ever ever
ever hired you
so for many many years i would like
renew my private contract with myself
it'd be like approaching may and i think
all right do we give it another year do
we go back all right let's give it
another year because i was working you
know and i was the minute you're getting
uh
the minute you're paying your rent
through your through performing right uh
for me it was the the minute i got out
of college and i was making some money
as a comedy writer
that extended my deadline right as long
as i'm i'm paying for my you must know
people and i certainly have known people
that have struggled for years with and
are
you know working as waiters or in stores
and and they will not give up the dream
and now they're 33 now they're 35. i
don't not regard that as
admirable and committed and and they're
saying
i'd kill to have something else to do i
want to follow my passionate road i get
it
and
and i just personally wouldn't have done
that i say to my kids you know three
kids i say you know i don't care if you
have any money at 30 but i would like to
think you had stumbled on some sort of
passion
and something's going to fuel your
interests throughout your life
the other stuff would come along but i i
just
knew it was a treacherous road but i i
was very lucky at the beginning you know
and i got all these things and i just
kept working all right we have the uh
the internet
i want you to frighten you with this the
internet's thought it was pronounced
internets please the less you say i
think that's the better that before this
is a device and i want you to be
frightened we have fans that are uh
watching
uh and i'm supposed to read you this fan
question we're gonna do two with you
maybe you need your trifocals
or are you pretending
that you don't wear them if i knew who
you were right now
i would insult you i cannot see beyond i
understand here we go joanne from
facebook asked did you ever develop a
character that no one would let you play
on tv or movies
um
no but you certainly would do characters
that wouldn't work out and you never saw
them again
i i remember an sctv i i was playing
an italian definitely there was a guy in
uh you know on the waterfront all he
would say is definitely
so my character was going a lot of
definitely
you saw it back
at the end of stan or whatever his name
was i mean he was gone we when i was at
starnot live i remember john lovitz was
you know he had the liar and he had he
had a couple characters hit
his master thespian he was obsessed
with getting another catchphrase
i love that syndrome he wanted that and
you've seen it a million times where
someone so badly wants i want my new
catchphrase
so
he
was convinced that it was a character
who said goodbye everybody goodbye
and that's all he had and he kept coming
up to us in the hallway and saying hey
you got any anything from my goodbye guy
i'd say like we i don't know what
leads into it i don't know and so he
started going on update and i don't know
if they've burned the tapes or what but
he started going on update and he'd say
like you know
well you know and dennis miller would
throw to him and he'd say thanks
everybody i think we're gonna have a
great time goodbye everybody goodbye
but anyway i think uh president reagan
is uh definitely uh is going to finish
his term so goodbye everybody goodbye if
you're watching it like this isn't he
needs to be hooked into something but he
was obsessed with goodbye everybody
goodbye it never took off and uh now
i've resurrected it john was uh
john is so funny it's so funny his
commitment his his original there is
only one john lovitz yes don't you think
yeah i mean he's covered he has one
brand of comedy i can see things i think
oh john levitz would have been better
than that because he has that thing
can you watch i always think john lovitz
if had he would have been uh
if he had been born in a different era
would have been signed up by a studio
to be the character actor who played
that one guy in every film because
that's how it used to work right he
would be that guy
that he played in uh you know um
the the women baseball movie
uh uh league of legends
yeah
but he would be a guy who always had a
pencil he'd be yes he'd be that
character and he'd be he'd be in 60
movies but i think because he now he's
to me a soul from another era that
because he was
only he was the only one who was living
with us in our present era
it made him
more provocative more original and a
bigger star yeah
um let me ask you quickly
can you watch
other people perform comedy
and lose yourself in it or is it next to
impossible you mean because i'm sitting
there with jealousy
there's
competitive
uh you can see the seams you can see
what they're doing oh they're going for
this they're going for that it's the old
number 53b
or can you lose i think truthfully if
it's the old number 53b no
but if i'm looking at um i remember when
i was when i was asked to go into
saturday live and i'd now finished sctv
and i was very hesitant because i had a
new baby and i really didn't
i just thought it just seems like so i'd
heard all this all the work and staying
on tuesdays and i just finished three
years of senate live and
i thought
i mean sctv and i thought
you know we'll just go to l.a we rented
a house
and uh dick ebersol phoned me up lauren
wasn't doing it then and said you know
would you like to do the show and and
this is who we're going after
and uh
there's billy crystal christopher guest
harry sure and
rich all these great people and i said
well
um if you get them phone me back and i'm
thinking you're not going to get those
chris chris guess isn't going to do
certain lives right and he said yes so
now i'm going to do it so now i have a
month and a half to think about it you
know
and i remember seeing spinal tap
and looking at it
going i can't i can't i can't be in the
same ballpark with these guys
this guy christopher guest is like i
knew billy billy and i had known each
other but i never met chris
knew harry a little bit i thought well
he's too brilliant i i can't i mean so
it wasn't for me
certainly it was not me sitting back and
saying oh he's making that move
i think actually
yeah i got last night so i think you can
get lost in it when uh spinal tap came
out it was a revelation yeah
now there's so much comedy and i'm sure
there's revelations for
people today younger people today i
don't quite know what they are but i'm
sure they're having those moments
themselves i remembered i think i want
to say it was 1983 or 84.
uh spinal tap came out or was it uh it
was the summer of 1984. yeah i remember
when it came out and just sort of hit
reset it hit the reset button right you
kind of go
so um
yeah i i
love to i mean bill hader to me is one
of the most brilliant fed armistan yeah
kristen wiig brilliant fantastically
talented people yeah and you can just
enjoy them yeah yeah um
okay uman
from facebook asks what's your favorite
song to sing in the shower
is that all there is
it used to be and then i stopped looking
down
incredible
i think that's pretty fast that was
fantastic thanks
ah that wasn't good
it wasn't clever and it was dated and
what is that song but it was 53 c
[Music]
uh i sing in the shower i'd like to sing
the shower i'm a big singer in the
shower
what do you like to say is it old show
tunes
no it's it's it's uh you're not singing
you know radiohead
you don't wash this quickly
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm doing no i
uh what am i doing
i got a feeling sometimes i'm making up
songs i got a feeling that today's gonna
be a sunshine day i do i do sometimes
i'll do that again i'm don't watch
anything i'm too busy performing my wife
occasionally
when we first oh she likes to sing in
the shower
anyway what's your question
sorry thought you knew
didn't
but i get it
she'll hear a whole i there's all kinds
of there's a show that goes on in my
bathroom every night and she has had
other people hear it she's singing no me
i'm just i'm
talking and saying now you're listening
here see i mean i'm i'm i i go and i i
if i'm
are you doing voices from old movies
like that or are you venting uh it's a
combination sometimes i'm venting so are
you venting in an old
vlog i will i will talk
i enjoy that era of speaking i grew up
on jimmy cagney
movies angels with dirty faces they've
showed them all the time and i love that
fast yeah patter
but there's a lot of me uh yelling and
confronting myself in the mirror and
shouting at a bar of soap and
um she's used to it which i find sad but
it's it's but you are medicated yes oh
yes heavily
as are we both and we'll be when we go
out to have dinner yeah i know we're
gonna have dinner tonight yes who's ping
it should be you
because i'm doing this
show
and it seems like it should be the show
picking up the tab traditionally
when i go with conan the bill just
sits there we keep going to the bathroom
hoping the other will take care of it
i've stayed in that bathroom
for two hours one time oh i was
crouching
i used to think you had an impediment in
your reach
i'm going to wrap this up
ah don't you want to get some stuff that
can be used
all right this was just us testing
we're testing the equipment thank you
thanks for having me drive to burbank
this will never ever be seen
i'm gonna end the way i started and
that's to say uh and i've been this
business a long time
this gentleman right here uh is in my
opinion the funniest guy out there and i
said something to you
at the vanity fair party and i'm just
dropping that because i don't get
invited a lot of places i ran into you
and uh i mentioned this to a lot of
people and i'll mention it to you and
i'll uh
i'll scream it to the rooftops every
year they talk about oscar hosts and i
think
who's funnier than martin short who's
actually has a body of film work
and young people think you're really
funny i think you're you'd be the
ultimate oscar host well thank you very
much
and i have no power in this town oh that
i know can't make it happen and my even
suggesting it may seal it's doom yeah
maybe people think wait a second we must
be nuts exactly uh
that i just wanted to get that out there
well you know personally i personally
think you are genetically engineered
to host that show genetically i think
you were built in a lab by nazis to host
the oscars and uh well
i think you would uh absolutely destroy
do you think in a way though truthfully
it's slightly a no-win situation that
you work for eight months and then they
say how about that adrian brody kiss
because it's about the oscars
i think
uh you would take a very long i would
enjoy all the moments that you were on
screen and i think
everyone else would enjoy all the
moments that you were on screen and
there'd be a couple of flamethrowers on
the internet that would say i didn't
like it when he said x y or z but no one
would care
you would be look at steve martin he
does it and people are satisfied they're
more than satisfied what about you doing
it let's be more realistic i have a thin
ready voice
i'm annoying
uh
i can't that be beneficial in a host i
guess not no not at all i have very uh
almost non-existent
genitalia i'm off-putting and i've made
a lot of enemies in this town the
conversation is you
you're the guy that should do it
and uh
what an epitaph yeah let's
the gravestone's been made
um do you know what says a my gravestone
what's that one word what's that almost
[Laughter]
i'm ending this only because i want to
go and have dinner yeah or in the sky
and there's going to be a lot of
drinking oh and chat and may i add
gossip
we're both mean
hollywood can we admit that we're mean
gossips yeah ah we're mean sons of
[ __ ] fantastic martin short there is
nobody funnier and they never will be
that's it for us jibber jabber blah blah
internet good night
you